you know get out of the mentality that
we have we get from schools and
universities where there's a reading
list where there's a set
syllabus where you cover it no we're
we're exploring the antarctic we're
exploring the polar regions we're we're
now on our own
and so
trust yourself
trust your inner curiosity don't don't
look for in a certain way in that regard
don't look for somebody to tell you what
to do
decide yourself and in a certain way
maybe my answer to those two questions
this question and the previous one is
you're on your life's journey
don't let somebody tell you what the
path is it's your path and forgive me
i've said this many times it's such a
beautiful idea and so everybody's
listening to this go buy every book by
joseph campbell you can buy and read it
he's a really incredible wonderful guy
who married one of his students who was
a dancer but
that be a side
uh so he says and i believe it's him
i'm not an academic so you know i got
steve goldstein from market watch
telling me that this academic work that
i've cited it doesn't exist somebody's
gonna find out about this but i'm
reasonably sure this is joseph campbell
he says
you enter the forest at the darkest
place
where there is no path
because if there was a path it wouldn't
be your path
and we each have to make our own path
and so you know in a certain way
underlying these questions is somebody
saying to me hey guy what's the path
and my answer is even if i knew the path
it's my path
you pick your path and don't ask me i
don't know
for you
and actually i would tell you that when
i have people doing kind of research
they kind of will ask me that those
kinds of questions and i give them the
same answer i say i don't want to tell
you what to look at i don't want to tell
you what the right way to look at this
industry is or which companies to look
at even because i want to find out what
you think
i don't want to find out what
i told you to think
and whether you agree with or not
or whether you i want you to start from
scratch you know
so
yeah
this one has changed
look i i'll give you why do i like you
tom i'll tell you one of the reasons why
i like you yeah i'm asking you i'm
asking a question and answering it
you're on your own path you're leading
you are a leader you don't know where
you're going but you know it's your path
you i don't know exactly where it came
from that you decided to do this podcast
i don't know where it came from that you
decided to come to the berkshire meeting
but you are on a path
that it's clear to me that nobody is
telling you
what to do you didn't wake up one day
and say i want to be do a pod you know
i'm going to ask
xyz person how to do a podcast how to
run a youtube channel how to be no
you're following your curiosity it's so
obvious that's actually part of what
makes it fun to talk to you
because you're alive you're making
decisions you don't know what you'll be
doing tomorrow in three weeks or two
years from now but you're you're
exploring your forest in a certain way
and it's a beautiful thing when you get
it because you're kind of there doing it
and so that's my answer and
here's a mistake that i have made
a pro
it's not um fatal thankfully but it's
kind of like a serious mistake in life
is that
i've made decisions as if i'm because i
was so in love with warren buffett i've
been making all these decisions in my
portfolio
that is that it doesn't come from
exactly where i stand it's maybe what
somebody with warren buffett's resources
would do if he was managing my portfolio
perhaps
but what
what is actually right for me there are
many small cap companies that i haven't
looked at because i've been too busy
aping warren buffett
but i have to actually look it's my path
it's not warren buffett's path it's not
lou simpson's path
my path you know and to the extent that
i found that i've been better and more
successful and you're clearly on your
own path
and so my exaltation to those two
questions is
try and find a way to be on your path
and the way you get on that path is i
can't you know is look inside yourself
you know in the in the words of that
famous book by the google engineer
search inside yourself the answers are
on the inside
um nobody knows which is the right step
for you to take nobody knows which is
the right textbook to pick up anymore
nobody knows which is the right company
to study
and and you don't know yourself but you
but every now and then you'll get clues
you know thomas to decide who he's going
to interview
and and i know that tom doesn't just do
it based on how many views they get he
looks inside himself you decide what do
my instincts tell me is the right way to
go forward it's a beautiful thing
actually i just realized it right now
back to you with a question
yeah i'll just quickly say it's more fun
to just do your own thing and talk to
interesting people rather than just try
to get the the most clicks but um
yes so here's here's what is really
fascinating tom
that uh again i'm not um i i i'm a lay
person in all of these things but i know
that there's a more than a kernel of
truth in it
is that um
your path
so
curiosity
is not just some weird thing that's out
there it's a there's there's processes
going on in our minds that are leading
us somewhere somewhere good
somewhere that uh somehow deep inside
ourselves or somewhere wherever the hell
it is
so so um
follow your curiosity because your
curiosity will lead you to a good place
follow your instincts
don't assume
that anything is extraneous
uh and and not something to be ignored
you know that also goes for the negative
sense and i i feel compelled to share
this i i hope it's relevant in some
weird way so
so so you know you sit in a room i'm in
a room
somebody peaks my curiosity and a friend
tells me oh that person's boring and not
interesting
don't listen to the friend listen to the
curiosity
don't assume that the reason why that
person caught your interest will be
obvious to you right away follow that
lead and see where it leads until you
know that it's not the right path for
you and then stop
that also goes in the negative the
famous or for me this
kind of impacted me so much to hear the
story so
you're a woman
you've worked late at night and you're
leaving your office say nine o'clock and
you're on the 10th floor of a 20-story
building and you walk to the elevator
uh you know all that there is is there a
security guard downstairs and you don't
have fuser anymore floors are deserted
and the elevator door opens and there's
a male figure
standing in the elevator and you get
this feeling of
um i don't know if that's safe and then
immediately because let's say you're a
woman living in a developed country you
say this is ridiculous i'm a female i
should feel safe leaving the office at
nine o'clock at night
uh i should not be worried about this
shadowy male figure in the elevator i'm
going to step in the elevator
and self-defense says
you don't step into the elevator even
though 999 times out of a thousand
there's absolutely nothing wrong with
that man in the elevator he has he bears
no ill will to you all those things
but you don't go into the elevator
because one time out of 999 it could
actually lead to an unpleasant
circumstance and all you have to do is
step away
go to the bathroom let the elevator
passed and stepped into a different
elevator where there's no shadowy man
standing inside that's listening to your
instincts that's an act of self-defense
in that case and i i was watching some
self-defense course that is an act of
self-defense listening to the instincts
not ignoring that feeling of i'm not
sure this is right for me and overriding
that feeling of well i should be allowed
to do that and just go with the
self-defense and the instinct on the
positive side
don't let a friend or somebody who's
well-meaning override those instinctual
short thoughts about where you should be
because that will lead you to the
promised land and that's what's led you
to kind of your promised land because
you're living the dream in a certain way
tom you're having a blast i can see it
you're having so much fun
you know yeah so so and it's special
when you connect up to people like that
so
you know it's strange you ask these
questions you don't know where the hell
is going to go
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you